As we just learned,
requests that
looked just like they came from
a form will not be preflighted.
You can't read the response
if course doesn't allow it.
But sometimes you might not
need to see the response
to wreak havoc.
Imagine a bank that has
a form to transfer money.
If you are not a good
person, all you want to do
is wire the money
to your own account.
You don't care about
what the server answers.
So you set up a
website that forges
a request of the same
URL the form uses and set
the parameters so that
the money is wired to you
and the user won't even notice.
That's why this kind of attack
is called Cross-Site Request
Forgery or CSRF.
Of course, banks have
sophisticated protection
mechanisms.
But for most purposes, a CSFR
token is protection enough.
A CSFR token is an
additional field appended
to a form that has been
put there by the server,
and it's stored
server site as well.
If someone is
submitting a request,
the CSFR checks that token
against the one it has stored
and only executes requests
if these tokens match.